I think it probably made people greedy
and there's no doubt about the fact that
a lot of positive things came out of it
you know you see beautiful buildings you
see you find yourself living in a city
that's very pleasant and you know you
don't see people suffering from poverty
and or you do perhaps but but a lot less
and but you know now that the bubble has
burst and the economy has collapsed I do
think it's a real blessing in disguise I
don't think there's any doubt about that
so much of you know I mean the great
music even in recent times and has not
come from wealthy spoiled children that
eat too much that are given too much the
tech stuff for granted it did come from
hard times and it did come from a
certain level of poverty and so I think
it's a blessing in disguise but I gotta
say having said that I did enjoy the
good times
yeah you notice a big difference now a
lot of restaurants closing a lot of
shops closing and you know people are
maybe a little bit panicked and the
media I think in Ireland hammered
consumer confidence and I think that
played a very big part in the bubble
bursting coming down so fast I think
that could have been avoided I think
people are now starting to get a little
bit bored with the recession and talk of
the recession and so I think that's a
good thing but but yeah you notice you
notice differences we've kind of stopped
celebrating and but we were over
celebrating so you know now it's evening
out a little bit I don't think that's a
bad thing